being a rockstar is easy think again
whether it's YouTube The Rolling Stones
or Madonna sooner or later every band or
musical act comes to a crossroads and
for the hard-rocking bands either that
moment of crisis is now the hard-rocking
post-grunge group as weathered the
departure of their lead guitarist as
well as a stint in rehab and have
managed to come out stronger than ever
with their new album holding onto
strings better left to fray but just
when cedar seems to be at its strongest
a new danger threatens to tear the group
apart as a band you have to keep pushing
yourself to the next level but this is
just wrong at first I thought it was a
joke but it's not a joke
Sean really loves Justin Bieber I think
Biebs has a good look I think he's got a
good sound it works
Seana started singing all our songs just
like Justin Bieber
[Music]
I feel so over laughs tonight you got me
feeling I can't deal with us anymore
this has to stop
especially the dance well the last few
months have been interesting but the
record company made some really good
points I hate the music but I love money
so I'm fine with the new arrangement the
guys have been great about our new
direction they didn't even blink when I
changed our band name Seba get it like
Bieber but Seba booyah Seether
or Sieber as they're now known have
returned to the studio to record a new
album to go with their new look so it
seems like crisis has been averted this
time or has it now I haven't told the
guys yet but I've discovered a new Muse
Taylor Swift anybody